Nó này mùa bày tháng 1 năm 2012, tông tin từ công an tình phút thọ, đơn vị vừa ra quy định khởi tổ vụ án,
khởi tổ bị cân đời với buổi nước nghĩa, sinh năm 1 yên chính trăm bệ mấy bày, chú xá thế lối, tình phút thọ,
về tổ, cảnh trở rất thông đường bộ.
Theo khi có đưa chá ban đầu, giờ định ông mỗi hải lòng, sinh năm 1 yên chính trăm sống mi sấu, chú xá mình xuyên, tình phút thọ,
tổ chức đam cựi trời còn vào các ngày 18 để nghệ 1 bộ táng 1 năm 2012 và thư vừa giữ nghĩa lắp dựng giọc gỷ.
Sáng 1 1 năm 2012, nghĩa tổ chức lắp dựng giọc gặp, mặc dù biết biết lắp dựng giọc trên đường liên thôn là đường giọc thông công cộp,
vì chính dụng việc hệ và 1 phần lòng đường chưa được cơ quan có thường quyền cho phép.
Chương ngày 1 1 năm 2012, xó khi đam cựi kết thúc, ra định chủ nhà yêu cầu thần giữa giọc đi trả lại mặt bằng giọt thông.
Giọc không giọc có kích thức lớn, quá trình thần giữa kéo dài như đến tối cùng ngày vẫn chưa hoàn tất,
nhiều cuộc chủ vẫn còn tổng tại chiến phần đường giọt thông.
Để khoảng 2012, anh đằng việc cơ, sinh 1,000, chúng ta mấy tắm, chú xá mình quyền, điều khiển xe 1 tổ và trảm và của chủ giọc gặp kối còn rất là rất đến bị thương hãng và tự vong xor đó.
Qua chiến đường tra bà đầu rất định, hành vi lắp dựng giọc giọc gặp cơ lên chiếm viê hệ, lòng đường không bảo đam, an toàn giọc thông của bụi đứn nghĩa là người nhân chức tiếp sẫn đến vụ tên nạn.
Đưa vơi hình viết của chủ hộ tổ chức đáng cưới, các quan đều trà đăng tiếp tục cung của hồ xa, tài liệu để sử lý theo quy định bảo đam tính như mình của pháp lật.